I'm Dr. Mike Roizen with a simple smart tip if you're trying to lose weight.
Try a new fruit.
Fill up your fruit bowl and get creative.
These are three fruits that are a great place to start.
Guava: It's rich in disease-fighting polyphenols...
...and can fill you up faster than blueberries or raspberries.
Just one 37-calorie guava has three grams of fiber.
Lychee is also packed with polyphenols.
And this tiny fruit has only six calories.
You can add it to celeries for extra flavor and dimension.
Papaya has loads of Vitamin C, which is great for your skin.
Vitamin C helps your body produce collagen, which makes your skin resilient.
These help keep your skin smoother.
Add a medium-sized papaya.
It's only 119 calories.
For more ways to look as young as your real age,...
...watch and share all of our smart tips right here.